[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA MURPHY: Ben Folds
is a singer, songwriter,
multi-platinum selling artist.
He's also a TV and film star.
He's done a number of things
outside of the music industry
that he should be very proud of.
He's a father.
He's a photographer.
He's also the
soundtrack of my youth.
No big deal.
[LAUGHTER]
My mom is here.
You can ask her.
BEN FOLDS: Hey.
LAURA MURPHY: She knows.
Yeah.
So we're super excited
to have you here.
Thank you so much.
It's a giant honor to
have you at Google today.
So--
BEN FOLDS: Well, thank you.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Thank you.
So we're going to do this
a bit differently today.
I know that most
of you in the room
know that Ben has a performance
tonight at the Fillmore.
So he's going to
reserve his voice.
Hopefully, you win tickets
so you can go hear him.
You have been completely
jam packed on this Fall
tour all the way
until, I think, I
saw your last show is
going to be in Honolulu.
So that may not be so bad.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's been a
pretty packed tour.
And it's called "The Paper
Airplane Request Tour."
So I thought what we could do
is just start off with tell us
why it's called that?
BEN FOLDS: Well, the second
half of the show, the set,
is requests.
And instead of people
shouting the request,
which is scary if
you're sitting on stage.
[LAUGHTER]
Close your eyes, you see
people with pitchforks.
They sound angry.
[LAUGHTER]
Because you can't
understand this.
And I just thought, oh, people
just make a paper airplane
and throw that.
So basically, I just
walk around the stage
and pick those up and play them.
I mean, it didn't
occur to me how many
songs that I had either written,
done, been involved with that
might be on stage.
So I brushed up on
a couple hundred,
and then I've got about
50 left that I just can't
seem to crack at the moment.
LAURA MURPHY: What's
one of those 50?
BEN FOLDS: Oh.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, stuff
like, there's songs
that I would have never
thought to play on the piano
by myself is why, like--
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
BEN FOLDS: So I did a movie
called "Over the Hedge"
for DreamWorks.
It was a kids' movie.
And the songs I wrote
for that, I never
expected to come back
to haunt me in any way.
[LAUGHTER]
The songs make me think
of conference calls.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: But,
yeah, so there's one
of those that's just like
kind of cacophony, horns.
It's a kiddie song.
I never thought about
playing it before.
But it's in the book
in case someone asks.
LAURA MURPHY: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN FOLDS: And
somebody yesterday
asked for something I wrote
when I was 16 years old,
which got on the internet.
I didn't know.
[LAUGHTER]
So--
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
BEN FOLDS: I
couldn't remember it.
LAURA MURPHY: Well
so on the flip side
of that, what's been
your favorite song?
Of all the paper
airplanes that have
landed on the stage, what's
been your favorite song to play?
BEN FOLDS: Oh, I don't know.
I don't really have
favorites of anything.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh.
Even of your own stuff?
BEN FOLDS: No.
Especially of my own stuff.
I think I've got a block there.
So, yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Well,
that's awesome.
BEN FOLDS: I try
to be a fair dad.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, so Ben is
really involved with his fans.
He's huge into social media.
And so what we thought we'd do
next is just kind of highlight
some of the ways that Ben
outreaches to his fans.
And what we'd love to do, since
we're on the topic of tour
is can you talk to us a little
bit about the VIP experiences
that you offer around soundcheck
before each of your shows?
And why you do that?
BEN FOLDS: Well, I
mean, quite honestly,
I do it because, you know,
if I'm going to tour,
I want to make the
most of it, you know.
I like touring fine, but
I also like being home.
So it takes care of a whole
lot of stuff at once on tour.
The normal-- I've been
approached about these a few
times, and didn't really want to
do them, because the ideas of--
look at-- Bon Jovi is great.
I think Bon Jovi is great.
I'm not making fun.
But the idea of
like, I think I'd
seen Bon Jovi standing
and taking pictures
with people for two hours.
And I don't want to do that.
But what we realized is we
could do something like a class.
So what we do is something
called a master class.
Not really a master class, but
it's almost a master class.
And then I will
let people come up,
if they want to play the
song, and we'll talk about it.
That's fine.
So it's like a
class for people who
are of any age that want to
talk about, commiserate about,
where they are in music,
or music education.
And we were bringing local
music teachers in to begin with,
because I think if you're
going to talk about music,
it's best to do it in
context of having learned it.
Which, as a rock
musician, you're
really supposed to put off
the idea that you rolled out
of bed one day,
and smoked a joint,
and started making up songs.
[LAUGHTER]
And you know,
between that point,
which is obvious that happened.
[LAUGHTER]
But at some point
you did learn it.
I'm a big fan of as much formal
training as possible in music,
no matter what kind
of music you make.
I think it makes it better.
So that gives me a
chance to do that.
It gives me a chance
to connect people
on things like National
Endowment for the Arts, which
was sort of tentatively was
up on the chopping block
for a little while.
And, you know, stuff.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
So the VIP, that makes
me feel good because I
feel like I'm hearing
from a lot of teachers,
I'm talking to people,
we're talking about music,
and it's not as much
of a celebrity affair.
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
BEN FOLDS: So it's given-- it's
been a good thing, you know.
It's actually-- and
I'm working on--
I think I'm writing a book.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
It seems that way.
I can't tell people
with a straight face
I'm working on my memoirs.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's good for that
too, because talking
to people about music all
the time, and of all ages,
and where they're
coming from, and how
they're learning
it is helpful to me
when I'm outlining
the things that I
think are important
when you're cramming
the music in your head.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
I think one of those
experiences is called
"Ask Me Anything" and then--
BEN FOLDS: Almost anything.
LAURA MURPHY: Almost
anything about music.
BEN FOLDS: AMAA.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
"Ask Me Almost
Anything About Music."
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: So you've had
some really interesting folks
come through.
Have you ever had anyone
that's blown you away,
or been really
musically talented?
BEN FOLDS: Oh, yeah.
I think almost everybody
who has bothered to step up,
play a song, has been
really impressive to me.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: And, yeah, and
sometimes-- a couple of days
ago, I was sort
of taunting a kid
to write a song on the spot,
because they were wondering
about-- every night of my
solo career just about,
since like 2002, I've sort of
had to freestyle songs onstage.
It's been a sort of
a tradition where--
I was playing in Chicago and
we were making a live album.
This guy goes, rock that bitch.
Rock this bitch.
And he just meant I wasn't
playing fast enough, or loud
enough, or something.
But we were making a
live album, and I made up
a song called that for him.
[LAUGHTER]
And that became popular.
So that it became a code word.
People would ask for that.
And I do it with
symphony orchestras
regularly, where I'll
freestyle a song,
and then I'll dictate parts
that I hear in the orchestra.
And so, yeah, I was
trying to get the kid
to put him in that position.
Let him make something up,
because we can do that.
LAURA MURPHY: That's awesome.
So, OK.
You're here at Google.
And we, beyond the
obvious search engine
that I'm sure you
use sometimes--
BEN FOLDS: I've
heard of it, yeah.
LAURA MURPHY:
You've heard of it?
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
We also own a little video
property called YouTube--
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: So
knowing all of that,
and knowing how involved
you are with your fans,
can you talk to us a little
bit about digital technology,
and how you use it to keep
in touch with your fans?
BEN FOLDS: To be
very honest, I think
my fans have always been the
types who are very ahead.
Always have been ahead.
To the point where
in 1999 I was signing
at least as many burned CDs.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was fine with that.
And I think that, because
I've embraced however
they want to be
excited about music--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: --and
open to it, it's
been really more of--
like now my management,
he comes from politics.
He doesn't know
anything about music.
And he also comes
from social media.
I personally have
been on Facebook
for a total of about
three minutes once.
To check it out,
and that's back--
LAURA MURPHY: This is
your Facebook page.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: In
case you wondered.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
It's right here.
BEN FOLDS: Well,
last time I did it,
people were sending me
emails about poking.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: That's
how far back it goes.
[LAUGHTER]
I do, you know, I do read
the news on my phone.
LAURA MURPHY: OK.
Good.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN FOLDS: I know that's
terrible, I just do--
LAURA MURPHY: Do watch
a lot of YouTube?
Do you use YouTube as a
resource for your music, or--
BEN FOLDS: I do.
Especially, like,
you know, one thing
is because I make up
a song every night,
sometimes I want to
remember what it was.
And people will always film it.
So--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: --I'll back.
In fact, one time
it came in handy
because had some guy being a
little bit of a jackass online,
saying that I'd stolen this
song from some guy I've never
heard of.
And he was kind of a famous,
like a comedian in the UK.
And so everyone was jumping
on the bandwagon saying,
oh, I thought Ben was better
than that, to steal a song.
And I'm like, I
don't even know--
I didn't really want to click
on that song they said I stole.
So I didn't even want
a record of ever having
heard this damn thing.
Anyway, I realized,
oh, wait a minute.
I made that song up on
stage mostly in 2011,
way before that guy had
his first record out.
LAURA MURPHY: That's funny.
BEN FOLDS: So I went on YouTube.
Found it.
Someone had posted it.
And sent that to
the guy in the UK.
He's like, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, will you have a press
conference now for me?
[LAUGHTER]
Because--
LAURA MURPHY: Will
you set this straight?
BEN FOLDS: --everyone
thinks I'm a thief.
I've been smeared.
LAURA MURPHY: That's awesome.
Well, so sort of in the same
vein of digital technology,
you have three children?
BEN FOLDS: Mhm.
LAURA MURPHY: And there's a
ton of folks here at Google
who are also working parents.
Do you allow screen time?
Do your kids use digital
technology for music research,
too?
BEN FOLDS: They do.
They live in it, you know?
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: They went to
Waldorf School for a few years
to wash them clean of it,
which I think is good, too.
I think a combination is good.
Some time off I think
was really good for them.
And then time on is good.
I don't really--
I think anything
can be addictive.
And certainly with
kids, iPads and stuff
like that can start to
seem to form an addiction.
But you know, short of
that, it's really amazing,
because they have
at their fingertips
all this information
that we didn't have.
And I think also they
learn pretty quickly how
to discern fake information, or
invalid information, I'd rather
not use the word fake anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
Invalid information
from valid information,
where my generation
wasn't ready for it.
We're like, whoa,
look at all that.
And I think, you know,
also like, you know,
e-mails, and things.
Like, they kind of
know how to do that
without getting in trouble.
There was a moment
in the Waldorf class
one year where two of the
kids had gotten on Instagram.
And they weren't supposed
to even be on it.
But they had gotten on
it, and were calling
each other horrible names.
I mean, stuff that--
I mean, look, I've said a
few bad words in my day.
I can't repeat the kind of
things they were saying.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
BEN FOLDS: They were so gross.
The teacher had them.
She printed it out,
as if it was a play.
[LAUGHTER]
And had them read it aloud
into each other's face
in front of the class.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
BEN FOLDS: And they
would say, well,
your mother is a f-ing B that
likes to cram Ds in her--
[LAUGHTER]
And you're like, wow.
And the teacher is like, I
don't think that's what it said.
Well, it said
something like that.
Well you're sitting
in front of him.
You say to him.
And that's what you're doing
when you put it online.
I think kids learn those things.
And so it's a different era.
I think in almost any
time-- the danger is talking
about it for someone
like me is because I've
been through all the eras.
And I think that
naturally we're all
programmed to think
that new technology has
some evil into the
world component to it.
It's like everything
that was ever
invented that was ever
important was just
a sign that the end was near.
And that's the way
our brains work.
So I sort of got out
of that business.
And I understand--
I'm not a total idiot.
There's an electric piano.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
I love that.
BEN FOLDS: So what
do I think of those.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
that's awesome.
All right.
Well, we're going to focus
on something else you love.
BEN FOLDS: OK.
LAURA MURPHY: Seemingly--
BEN FOLDS: Something
else besides--
LAURA MURPHY: --that you love.
BEN FOLDS: --besides
digital media.
LAURA MURPHY: Besides
[LAUGHTER]
Photography.
BEN FOLDS: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: So, if you guys
haven't checked this out,
Ben has one of the most
amazing photography sites.
It's a split between
his music career
and his photography,
where he is actually
selling a lot of his work.
A lot of his work
is highlighted.
So we wanted to just kind of
ask you about a couple of these.
I understand those might
be your own children?
BEN FOLDS: That's them.
LAURA MURPHY: Is that right?
BEN FOLDS: Would
you run it back one?
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, sure.
Of course.
BEN FOLDS: Anyone know
the movie, "The Room?"
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BEN FOLDS: Like, you
know, Tommy Wiseau?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: My daughter drew this
whole big collage of the room,
with all the quotes randomly
from it, when she was 14.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
that's awesome.
BEN FOLDS: It's really good.
That's what--
LAURA MURPHY: That's
what this poster is?
BEN FOLDS: That's what that is.
LAURA MURPHY: Is her name Lisa?
BEN FOLDS: No, no.
Lisa is one of the characters.
So you're tearing
us apart, Lisa.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, sorry.
I just noticed that
was in the picture.
LAURA MURPHY: [LAUGHS] OK.
So these are-- is
this one of your--
BEN FOLDS: That's
Louie and Gracie.
There were about-- maybe I--
I'm going to guess
they were six?
Five?
They were probably five.
LAURA MURPHY: I love the
back story on this, too.
And you can find
this out on his site.
Ben-- they were in a hotel.
He was on tour.
And he had just gotten
incidentals for the hotel room,
and was kind of maybe
obsessing over how much he
spent on bottled water.
BEN FOLDS: Bottled water, yeah.
Like $100 or something.
LAURA MURPHY: And then
captured this amazing moment
of your children, just kind
of taking in all the scene
outside of the hotel room.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
There were people
watching 20 floors below.
It's kind of cool.
LAURA MURPHY: And you're friends
with a bunch of famous people,
too.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah, that's--
LAURA MURPHY:
[LAUGHS] Bob Sagat.
BEN FOLDS: It's Bob and Jeff.
Yep.
Bob Sagat, yep.
LAURA MURPHY: I just picked
a couple of, you know--
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Your
work is all amazing.
But some of the
stuff-- it seems to me
you're really interested
in photographing people,
and somewhat, obviously,
your performances, but
behind the scenes, too, as well.
But actually, this
is what I was hoping
you could talk to
us about, because I
found this really fascinating.
He's got-- Ben has three
photos of his experiences
at Bonnaroo in 2006,
2008, and 2012.
But I believe, if
I'm not mistaken,
fact check me on this, Ben,
this was the first time
you asked the audience to--
BEN FOLDS: Yeah, that's right.
LAURA MURPHY: --flip you off.
BEN FOLDS: Flip me off.
Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
So talk to us a little bit
about what inspired that?
And what became a sort
of somewhat like--
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
When you see that first
one enlarged, because it's
a pretty big negative,
you can see people happily
flipping me off all the
way back to about 50,000,
60,000 people back there.
[LAUGHTER]
And then I just--
it became a thing.
I just asked them to do that.
Stand on my piano with very
large camera and photograph it.
I get myself one or two
shots really quickly.
But, yeah, you can how they--
someone must've
dehydrated it this year.
And then they've got the
trough through the middle
so they go in and out.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
and then they're just--
BEN FOLDS: And the
trees change some, too,
which is kind of cool.
Not so much between these
two, but the first one.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: Anyway.
LAURA MURPHY: Is that something
that you do other performances?
BEN FOLDS: No.
LAURA MURPHY: Or is it
just special for Bonnaroo?
BEN FOLDS: That's just Bonnoroo.
Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: [LAUGHS]
That's awesome.
All right.
Well, one of the
things, a connection
back to Detroit,
one of the things
that I love about what
you do-- you spoke
a little bit about this when you
are performing with orchestras
or symphonies, and someone
shouts out, what was it?
Rock this bitch?
Or rock that bitch?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: I just
think it's unbelievable
how then you take 10 15 minutes,
whatever it takes, to compose
that song sort of live.
So I was hoping you could talk
to us about your experience
with the Detroit
Symphony Orchestra,
since you're here in Detroit.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
Detroit has a great
symphony orchestra.
I mean, they really do.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, they do.
BEN FOLDS: It's a real--
and Grand Rapids actually
does, too.
AUDIENCE: Rock this bitch!
BEN FOLDS: Oh, shit!
[LAUGHTER]
And since [INAUDIBLE] I'll
do it in monotone today.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
What can I say?
I don't-- then I can
see the conductor.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
But, yeah, they've got a
great symphony orchestra.
They really do.
When it comes to the rock this
bitch moments with the symphony
orchestra, they're
all a little different
in terms of how
receptive they might
be as an organization to
that, because they have
a lot of rules
about they show up,
and they understand
what they're playing,
and they're not put in
a position of looking
like they're not prepared.
You know, it's-- that really--
I understand why
that's not fair.
But they're all--
they've all relaxed.
Detroit was fine about it.
And they're relaxed a
lot, because I think
they can see that it works.
It humanizes the
orchestra to me,
because the audience sees
the orchestra as something
that may well just be
stuck in the 19th century.
I mean they don't really look--
you don't see it.
It's not a personal thing.
An orchestra is not a
diva-oriented individual
or thing.
And it did not come from.
It came from the whole
thing as one group.
And when you see people
reacting differently to how am I
going to do this thing
that he's asking me to do?
And having to kind of sit up.
And they're very proper
classical musicians
are asked to do this.
I think that's interesting.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: And it's interesting
for the orchestra, too.
Puts their ear to the test.
And it's good for me,
because it teaches me--
I mean, there's-- you
can't learn enough about
orchestration.
It's such a wormhole.
It's an art that takes years.
And part of the reason that
we have trouble with it
now is because most
of the orchestration
is done on the computer.
And the computer
doesn't actually
give you a real idea of what
it sounds like, in the space.
It does an amazing thing with
telling you the theory of it.
But the real art of
orchestration is that.
So I get to be
onstage and go, oh, I
was wondering what
it would sound
like if I put the piccolos
two octaves above the bassoon
and have them do this.
And then I get to hear it there
on the spot, which gives me
nightly orchestration lessons.
Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Do you let the
crowd also shout out the song?
Or when they say,
rock this bitch,
do you decide what song
you are going to arrange?
BEN FOLDS: No.
I just make it up.
I think the last time--
I believe here was--
I think there was
a woman who asked--
LAURA MURPHY: Detroit
Rock City, was it?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah, that
may be what I did.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, so I had them--
I knew there were some--
I had my tour manager
print the lyrics
to the Kiss song,
"Detroit Rock City,"
and I made up a whole new
orchestral melody had nothing
to do.
It has nothing to do
with the original music.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: It's interesting
to attend a symphony
and hear hecklers.
It's not usually something
that you hear, but--
[LAUGHTER]
But really, in this case,
it's become something.
Do you hear it at
your other shows, too?
Do you ever get someone--
BEN FOLDS: You don't think
of the symphony they like,
more Adagio!
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: [INAUDIBLE]
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: How do you
deal with hecklers otherwise?
Or is that not really a
thing, because your fans
are so ingrained with you?
BEN FOLDS: I think most of
my audience is pretty nice.
People speak up.
But that is the thing
with the orchestra,
in that it's gone through--
historically, it's gone
through a lot of periods.
In Mozart's time,
is good example,
it was coming back to
a more informal time.
And he encouraged people
to clap between movements.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: You're
looked at as an idiot
if you clap between
movements now.
Used to be--
I mean, there have been
eras of classical music
where they drank, played folk
songs in the middle of it,
composer would bring out
one of his new tunes,
but then would play all
kinds of other stuff.
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
BEN FOLDS: So it's
become another thing.
And I think it's
intimidating to people.
And so, you know, I think it's
nice that they can actually--
I don't think heckling
is probably great.
But I think it's good that they
can feel comfortable enough
at the symphony to be a little
less formal, I think is good.
At the same time, I think
that the symphony orchestra,
as an institution, needn't dumb
a note down at all in order
to accommodate for that, or in
order to bring in more people.
They don't have to play
like children's movie music,
and put a screen up,
and shit like that.
LAURA MURPHY: That's true.
So you're basically our
modern day Mozart with this.
BEN FOLDS: Oh, no.
LAURA MURPHY: So, thank you.
[LAUGHS]
BEN FOLDS: I've already
lived a lot longer.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: So,
outside of this,
any other connections
to Detroit?
We know you're playing at
the Fillmore tonight, which
is an unbelievable venue.
Then--
BEN FOLDS: The Fillmore
was the State, right?
Am I right?
LAURA MURPHY: Correct.
BEN FOLDS: When it
was a State Theater--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: --I was
very excited to have--
when I went solo
was right around--
my album was released,
first solo album
was released on 9/11.
And that was pretty much it.
Anyone who put out a record
that day, there was nothing.
You didn't hear more
from that record.
The record was called
"Rocking the Suburbs."
And it pretty much
died commercially.
And so I went out and
played solo for a while.
And the idea was that I
probably couldn't play anymore
to like to 250 people, and
that was it for my career.
That's what was
discussed in my circle.
It was pretty
much, this is over.
Your album's not doing well.
You're going to play for
a couple hundred people,
and if you're cool with
that, then keep doing it.
I was like, that's fine.
I'll just do that.
So we got in a van, and
I just went solo piano.
And over the course of the
year, we went from our 250
to selling out places
like the State.
So it all came back.
And it was fine
The State Theater
was one of those
that I was really excited
about having sold out.
It was in a row of ones like.
Problem is, is I came
down with pneumonia
and played the State
Theater with a 105 fever.
LAURA MURPHY: Ugh.
AUDIENCE: Oh!
BEN FOLDS: And I did the
whole thing like that.
And then, just
because I'm stubborn,
I decided I'm going to
walk out on the sidewalk.
It's two degrees outside.
And signed shit for 45 minutes.
And then I did the same thing
in Chicago, the next night.
Still it just ran--
like, I would break down
to like 102 and go back up 105.
I was about to have
some kind of fit.
LAURA MURPHY: Wow.
BEN FOLDS: It was
terrible on your brain.
And I play Chicago,
and I fell over.
A total VH1 "Behind the Music."
I walked off the stage,
and all of a sudden,
I just kind of
remember, like, it's
going to be really
embarrassing if I pass out
in front of people.
And I made it to the soundboard.
And there was a really
nice, good-looking guy
with shaved, bald
head in a suit.
It was a security guy.
And he's like, I got you.
[LAUGHTER]
I think he carried
me downstairs.
And I woke up back home.
LAURA MURPHY: Did
you stop your tour?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Oh.
I hope--
BEN FOLDS: But I made
it to that point.
Like, I made it--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: --my career
[LAUGHS] was back.
[LAUGHTER]
My health, not so much.
LAURA MURPHY: Nothing a
little pneumonia can't cure.
[LAUGHS] Well, I'm sorry.
I'm glad you're
feeling better now.
We're glad you're here
and healthy tonight.
BEN FOLDS: All better.
LAURA MURPHY:
[LAUGHS] All right.
So--
BEN FOLDS: I was trying
to think of a Detroit
story I remembered.
I like the book store.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, anything?
BEN FOLDS: That John King
bookstore, I love that.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
that's a good--
BEN FOLDS: That's fun.
LAURA MURPHY: The
John King bookstore.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: The city
is alive right now.
BEN FOLDS: It's neat.
LAURA MURPHY: It's come back.
BEN FOLDS: No, it really has.
It's really neat.
LAURA MURPHY: Our office
is making a move down
to Detroit next year, so--
BEN FOLDS: Cool.
LAURA MURPHY: --when
you're back in town.
BEN FOLDS: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURA MURPHY: Any other--
BEN FOLDS: Oh, I know
this is Birmingham.
That's right.
LAURA MURPHY: This
is Birmingham.
BEN FOLDS: We were
talking about Detroit--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: But--
BEN FOLDS: I do like to
watch that Sports Illustrated
and there's a special.
I think it's called "30 for 30"
on the bad boys on the Pistons.
I've seen it like
five times now.
[LAUGHTER]
It's so fun.
LAURA MURPHY: And Dennis Rodman
is, of course, your favorite.
BEN FOLDS: Oh, I
think he's amazing.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I do.
What a character.
Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: He is.
OK.
So in the vein of
music, any other bands
you're into right now?
BEN FOLDS: No.
LAURA MURPHY: Anything-- no?
BEN FOLDS: It's just me.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Perfect.
Yeah, that's good.
BEN FOLDS: I may
as well be honest.
No.
You know, I just listen to
a lot of stuff that's not--
I mean, I don't know.
I-- the way I feel about it
right now, at this moment,
is that if something
really, really
catches my ear for a
really profound reason,
I'll go back and revisit.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: Otherwise, at this
very moment, I'm so much more
caught up with
200 years of music
that I missed because
I wasn't born yet.
And that's a lot of great
stuff to catch up on.
LAURA MURPHY: Mhm.
BEN FOLDS: My job was to
know about it all the time.
And now I just kind
of feel like it's
a relief not to have to
know every little crappy
thing that comes out.
Because there's some really
interesting and good stuff,
too.
But I don't find it
anymore inspiring to hear
someone's indie rock mating
call, which is essentially
what it is, next to say the
housekeeping person singing out
in the hall that
might sound amazing.
To me, it's like,
well, that's great.
That's great music.
And I don't have
to hear everything.
But when something
really great comes out,
you know, like I think the last
few things that really struck
me were, one, Caroline Shaw.
I think Caroline Shaw
is just a damn genius.
And I liked Dirty
Projectors, but I
think maybe they're gone now?
Are they still--
AUDIENCE: Still
going [INAUDIBLE]..
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
OK, good.
I like Dirty Projectors.
You know, and every
once in a while I hear
something on the radio I
think it's kind of cool.
I like that one
Justin Bieber song
about how you've got
to love yourself.
That's pretty good.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
So, music today sucks.
But the stuff that you're--
BEN FOLDS: No, I don't think so.
I think music it is incredible.
I think I don't see the need
at the moment to package it.
I just-- my head's
not in that space.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: I'm not
excited about the--
it almost feels like
Vogue magazine covers
to me, even the good stuff.
I just can't get my head
around it, at the moment.
That's just honestly
where my head's at.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, how are
you consuming that other 200
years of music?
Are you listening to it on
vinyl, cassette, digital?
BEN FOLDS: Wherever
I can get it.
I don't-- like, I'll look
at it, like, you know,
like YouTube is great.
So I go--
I went down a Bernstein YouTube
wormhole a couple of years ago
that now has become sort
of like my favorite thing
to do if I can't sleep,
is to go on there.
I mean, I did go
on YouTube recently
and see people's videos
about their pet pigs.
[LAUGHTER]
I could have been listening
to new music, but I was--
there's a site called
Squeals on Wheels.
I want--
[LAUGHTER]
I want to buy--
the one that I really was
in love with, she's gone.
She's someone--
someone picked her.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: That's amazing.
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: Very fascinating.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So, Ben, there's--
BEN FOLDS: Hey, I
want be clear though.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, yeah.
BEN FOLDS: I think there's
a lot of great music.
I really do.
I'm not cynical
about it that way.
I think people are
having amazing ideas.
And it's evolving.
And a lot of it's evolving
because how incredibly
fast ideas are being exchanged.
But the packaging of
it, and the ambition
of succeeding with it,
and essentially it's
mating music for about
15 years of your life.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: And now that's
all I can really hear in it.
Like--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: I see the mirror
and the hairbrush and stuff.
And it makes me want to listen
to Ravel string quartets.
That's all.
LAURA MURPHY: Are you a Spotify,
or a Pandora, or a digital--
when you're on the road,
and you don't have access
to some of those
other outlets, are you
listening to online
or web-based music?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah, I mean,
I'll grab it wherever
I can to show somebody.
I liked the idea of
Pandora when it came out.
I listen to comedians that way.
I think it's kind of fun
to put in one comedian
and see who else pops up.
It's kind of interesting.
I thought their sort of idea I
thought was really interesting.
So I sort of agree with it.
I don't keep up with the sort
of intellectual property rights
issues on anything.
I never had it out for Spotify,
or Pandora, or any of those.
LAURA MURPHY: Nabster?
Or anything?
BEN FOLDS: No, no.
I wrote letters on
behalf of Nabster
when they were held up in
some court in California.
And I think I might
have been the only one,
besides I think maybe Chuck
D was doing that, as well.
I was asked to do all
these appearances about how
they were stealing music.
And I couldn't get on with that.
I've never agreed with that.
I don't even agree with it
when someone sues someone
over a song that sounds
like their old song.
There's just not enough
chords and melodies
for me to get on with that.
I don't understand it at all.
I know that people have
to make money at it,
and I can see that technology
sent musicians back from,
hey, I could make
millions of dollars to oh,
I might be standing out on
the street with the monkey
and piano scrolls again.
But that was a really
short period of time
where musicians
became millionaires.
And so the fact that we got sent
down from that by technology,
at least for a little
while, you know, oh, well.
I mean, I'm not sure that--
I think there's--
I would rather be
concerned about the cutting
of the National
Endowment for the Arts,
or paying schoolteachers,
or something than I would
at making musicians, like
myself, millionaires.
I mean, look--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: I'm cool with it.
I'm happy to be one at any time.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think the
technology has made
people excited about music.
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
BEN FOLDS: It's created some
legal problems, which are
the legal people's problems.
That's--
[LAUGHTER]
That's for us to all deal with.
Seriously.
LAURA MURPHY: They
need jobs, too.
BEN FOLDS: When you--
when you-- it's right.
When you make up a
thing, and you're like--
I mean, god, I was
watching the Ken Burns
thing on the Civil War and
about how many people were
killed then because technology
had outpaced tactics.
Well, it was time for
tactics to catch up,
so people get killed at
it, because that's just
the way it is.
And so I feel like
we're catching up.
And that the music industry
seems, from what I hear,
to be more robust again.
And everyone can not
worry that technology is
the end of the world anymore.
But we may find
ourselves, as musicians,
questioning the value
of a note or a song.
And it used to be pretty clear.
Like a song is 1/10 of
an album, and an album
is worth 12.99, or
something like that.
You know, then that
change to-- technology
redefined it and said,
no, actually, a song
is worth nothing.
You know, it was like, oh,
OK, is it worth nothing?
Well, but people started
becoming music therapists,
and doing other things
with their lives.
And music then-- it's
found to sell other things
when it's packaged with it.
And music has always
needed context.
So to me, it's all just
always going to be a mess.
Which is part of the reason I
think I sort of divorced myself
from it all, except for
being someone that goes,
oh, I want to find that song.
And I just put in a search
and wherever it comes up,
I play it.
LAURA MURPHY: It's
interesting you say that,
because I was going to ask
you about this quote of yours.
But another quote of
yours that I love so much,
you were doing an
interview where you said,
write the bad songs.
Like writing the bad songs
could be one of the best things
that you do.
So if you would talk--
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: --a
little bit more
about what you think
may bad songs are?
Or why you think that theory?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah, well, I
mean, I think you have to be--
and I think almost--
this is almost cliche.
I mean, in any artist I think
worth anything will probably
admit that you need
to be OK with failing.
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
BEN FOLDS: I mean, you
have to be OK with failing.
LAURA MURPHY: Right.
BEN FOLDS: But,
you know, the chips
are going to fall to an extent.
You're always collaborating.
Kind of like what I'm
saying about technology.
It is like a song collaborating
with the circumstances.
You can't be responsible for
the rest of the circumstances.
You're collaborating your half.
If someone's religious, they
can say the other half is god.
If they want to say
it's the universe,
they can it's the universe.
And they can say it's
mistakes or chance.
But you're collaborating
with something.
If I'm writing a
song right now, it's
going to be a different song
than I would write if you
put me in another situation.
You know, so you have to be
OK with the dynamics of life.
Without the downs, you don't
have the ups, well, you
don't have the downs.
And you know, it's kind of
like people worry about,
I don't know, you know, like
music businesses going out
of business.
I'm sure they worry
about news, for instance.
But people will consume news.
People need it.
And so it's going to happen.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah
BEN FOLDS: Someone-- we're
all going to figure this out,
because you're not going to
unsee the technology that you
have.
And I think the same thing is
true when you think of a note.
Or you think of
a part of a song.
It's like, well, that was bad.
Well, that's part of your life.
You know, so now
maybe that spurs you
to think of something better.
But there's got to be
a trajectory running.
And I think that one of the
things about improvising
a song in front of
an audience always
reminds me about those moments.
It reminds me that things
have to shift in order to save
something that's going down.
And then it goes
up, and it's never
what you think it's going to be.
If you knew what
it was going to be,
you would have
written a song before.
It would have
already been there.
There's a point
where you're writing
and it's just ahead of
you, and it's coming out.
And if what you've done is just
gone down the roller coaster
to the bottom, then
you get to head up.
And if you apply your ego
to writing songs too much,
you assume that every note has
to be taken as the best thing.
Every phrase.
I have when people say,
like, that's a good line.
Ugh.
I don't give a shit about that.
Like I want a trip.
It's not like a list of
quotes from John Bartlett's
book of quotes.
LAURA MURPHY: Mhm.
BEN FOLDS: It's like
life, which does that.
LAURA MURPHY: A story.
BEN FOLDS: It's a story.
Like, that's
actually what it is.
It's a story.
And you don't know
what the story is.
That's part of the story.
You haven't gotten there yet.
[LAUGHTER]
So when you're improvising on
stage, or you're making a song,
embracing the moments that seem
to you, judgmentally, to be bad
is you have to get through
it to get to the next point.
You can't decide
to just dismiss it.
It's like, you know,
like it's scientifically
proven when you sneeze
and you repress it,
it blows up all
your brain cells.
It's not.
But if sneeze--
LAURA MURPHY: Scientifically.
BEN FOLDS: Yes, scientifically.
LAURA MURPHY: Scientifically--
BEN FOLDS: If you sneeze, cough,
and burp at the same time,
your heart will
stop and you'll die.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah, I heard it's
impossible to do that, right?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah, you'll die.
LAURA MURPHY: No
one's ever done it.
BEN FOLDS: No
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Well, wow.
BEN FOLDS: I hope you just
cut these little bits out--
[LAUGHTER]
--and just put those
online, so people learn--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: --lessons.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, yeah.
We'll do that take.
We'll just more quotes
from you up on--
BEN FOLDS: Yeah,
that I don't even
acknowledge when I'm talking.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just like, whatever
that said, I don't know.
I'm just going to talk.
LAURA MURPHY: Well--
BEN FOLDS: Is that
my handwriting?
It looks really--
LAURA MURPHY: No,
that's-- that's-- no.
BEN FOLDS: It's very consistent.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Very.
Well, OK, so at
this point, I want
to make sure I don't
hog all of you,
because there's a ton
of questions out there.
So does anyone have
any questions for Ben?
Someone want to be brave
and kick us off here?
BEN FOLDS: Come at me, bro.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, we
got one right here.
AUDIENCE: You're clearly
an entrepreneur of works.
Did you start out seeing
yourself that way?
Or did that come about
through your career?
Or do you not see
yourself that way at all?
BEN FOLDS: Oh, I think
entrepreneur is a great--
I think it should be
acknowledged more often,
that musicians, recording
artists, actually most of us
are, and have that gene.
Mostly because I
found when I started
to do arts advocacy
on Capitol Hill,
and I'm talking to a lot of
Senators and Congressmen,
I could see a real
discrimination
against the artist as
being someone who obviously
doesn't understand numbers.
And I'm wanting to
say, look, bitch,
I can balance a checkbook.
Because I started for like
five years in a van on fumes.
Like a rock band knows that they
have a business that they're
running, looks for
the opportunities,
is creative about it.
And at the same
time, has to balance
the checkbook, has to get from
A to B, knows how to do it.
I didn't inherit,
you know, a lot
of money like a lot of
these guys that I go in
and talk to have.
And so I consider
myself with quite a chip
on my shoulder probably
a lot better businessman.
And I think as far
as entrepreneurship,
yeah, I mean, you know,
I think most creative--
it's a matter of
culture that we would
prefer to see our artist as,
you know, the guy who rolled out
of bed, smoked a joint, saw
the future, and wrote about it.
I think that sells
human beings short.
And I enjoy seeing
an opportunity--
a thing that hasn't
been covered.
That's totally capitalistic.
Like, this is awesome.
I can make a shit ton of
money doing that, you know?
I think that's fun.
Like, I recognized when we
started that there were no--
you did not go to a rock show
and see a piano, a real piano,
on stage.
So I thought, well,
I could probably
bypass a whole lot
of competition,
if I just bothered to move a
baby grand piano onto a stage.
That's so audacious.
So we played our punk rock
clubs where we weren't welcome.
It was-- I think it was
probably threatening
the establishment
of the punk rock
community, which I enjoyed.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like it turned
them into the old man.
You can't put piano
on that stage, kid!
[LAUGHTER]
And yeah, and ever since then,
I still do the same thing.
And you know, as far as kind of
running the business part of it
goes, and to tie it back to
technology, if I were a CEO,
I would be the kind
that would be fairly
hands off about the
technology but said,
I recognize that you
three people, you kids,
seem to be very
interested in this.
So go nuts.
Throw it all against the
wall, see what happens.
LAURA MURPHY: You would
empower your people.
BEN FOLDS: I-- absolutely.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah
BEN FOLDS: That's, I
mean, that's always been.
I mean, we, as a
result, like, I think
I played the first
Myspace broadcast
and have all these
things are sort of first.
Like I think I put the
first iTunes EPs out.
Had three number one
records on iTunes
because there wasn't that
much competition yet.
Tried to do it with no CDs.
This was in 2003 maybe,
tried to do it with no CDs,
and vinyl and digital.
Just because I thought
that would be cool.
And you guys just take it
and make it do something.
You know, and I enjoyed
that way of doing it.
But [INAUDIBLE]
entrepreneurship.
But I like that word,
and I think it's cool.
I think more artists--
I mean, look, Charles Ives,
one of our great composers
of the turn of the century,
20th century, he did two things.
He made some of our most really
distinct creative or original
avant garde American music.
And he also revamped
the insurance business,
life insurance business.
That wouldn't be cool in
the '90s, if Kurt Cobain had
said, yeah, man, I was just
thinking about life insurance.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, like that doesn't
work in my generation much,
but I think it's cool.
AUDIENCE: How did you
get out and convince
these bars and punk rock clubs
to let you you play there?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And when
in your career
did you realize that
you were finally--
or what did you do to
get to the next level?
BEN FOLDS: Well, it had
been such a long time.
You know, this is--
you're obviously
talking when I was
like 27-years-old when
the band started.
LAURA MURPHY: And
you're 28 or 9 now?
BEN FOLDS: Four.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: One other
thing to add to that.
Did you know when you
started that that's
where you wanted to get?
Or was it just for
fun at the beginning?
BEN FOLDS: A little bit of both.
I came from working class south.
And that's-- being
a musician is not--
that's not even cool to say.
I mean, I think like in
the equivalent in the UK
might actually be kind of cool
to be a musician, if you were--
but I think it's like
singing, nah, that's off.
That's-- You're a sissy.
But playing music is only
something that, you know,
that some sort of
elite fruitcakes
with like tight
leather pants do.
You could teach, but
who wants to do that?
So I kind of kept it to myself.
I kept my whole-- but I
knew I was a musician.
I think I knew I
was going to do it.
I was stubborn about it.
And, you know, I spent from
when I was maybe 18 to last year
when I was 27--
[LAUGHTER]
That's really
supposed to be funny.
[LAUGHTER]
You know I wrote songs,
and sent them in as tapes,
and tried to do-- tried to
get the approval that one
would need to make a record.
And I wasn't getting it.
So I just started doing
what I wanted to do,
which is to play shows.
I had-- if I remember, it was a
little bit of a rocky long ride
on this piano business,
putting pianos in.
Because I fought to do that.
And I borrowed
some money somehow,
I got some kind of little
loan, to get a piano.
And then I snuck back to
the soundboard at a really
kind of small Elton John gig to
talk to a sound man about how
he made his piano loud,
because I was at the show,
and I was like,
well, I can hear it.
Which I happened to know
was really difficult to do,
because we'd stuck
mics in at one time
and you couldn't hear it.
It didn't work.
So we found out some
technical things.
And it was just all long trips.
That was maybe one was like 22.
So between 22 and
27, it was just
a matter of me being stubborn
and trying to figure out
how to amplify the piano, should
I ever find myself in a rock
band to put it on stage.
And it's just a real
long road, I think.
But it's good because I
would say in that time
I sort of found my voice.
I became increasingly
stubborn, because I
started to realize the
folly in trying to get--
in trying to get approval.
And I started to realize the
advantage of placing yourself
in positions that seemed
insane, like the idea
of rolling yourself between
some band called Fucking Death
Grip and Santa's Cock.
[LAUGHTER]
And playing-- sorry, just
whatever comes to my head.
[LAUGHTER]
And playing a piano
rock show between that,
and then going back to
waiting tables the next day.
And as I saw that
working, but slowly.
So we would try to book gigs.
I had a couple of friends,
and we were trying to--
I had some help, but I was
mostly doing it myself.
Try to book a gig,
and of course,
they'd say, yeah, we can
put you on on folk night
over at this place.
And there's a upright piano
when they're drinking tea.
It's like, no, I kind
of want to play in the--
and I think we should play
like opening up on a Monday
night for a grunge band.
I think that would be better.
It just took a while.
I had to turn down
a lot of stuff.
Also, we had to
turn down anything
that the piano
wouldn't fit into.
For like three to five
years of touring, even
with an indie record
label behind us,
they would want
us to play a place
like called Eddie's Attic.
Well, you can't move
a piano up to that.
We were moving it ourselves.
I mean, I can move a
grand piano myself,
out of here onto a
truck, and off she goes.
I just learned how to do it.
I figured it out.
And you know, that's
kind of the trip.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Oh--
BEN FOLDS: I'm sorry.
But it enabled me to see
something that I've always--
well, I-- sometimes, you
just want to see a thing.
Like, if I made a
movie, I'd go, oh, I'd
like to make a Victorian
love story, and at the very
end the spaceship lands, and
some orange guy gets out of it,
and starts saying crazy shit.
You know, like, you can
do anything you want to,
if you put your mind
to seeing something,
even if it's a little
odd that you want to see,
then you're the
only one doing it.
And I think that's
worked, luckily.
Most the time.
Sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes it doesn't
work at all, you know.
LAURA MURPHY: I
think we only have
time for one more question.
Is there
anything--
BEN FOLDS: Especially if
I don't talk that much.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah?
Lindsey?
AUDIENCE: So if you to
write a song for Google,
what would the story, I guess,
because we're not saying words,
what would that be?
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: That's
a good question.
BEN FOLDS: Well, I wouldn't
write that right now.
[LAUGHTER]
Because it'd be
really-- it'd be vapid.
But I-- it would
probably be about--
it would probably be about being
with a bunch of cigar-smoking
fat guys in the front of--
like in the first
class of an airplane.
And then the next time I
went in, it was all guys that
looked like me, the next trip.
[LAUGHTER]
Like something like that.
You know, something
to show, because I
think there was a
change when I realized
that the first class
went from being
fat cigar-smoking white guys
to a whole variety of people,
many of them that
looked like me.
And it happened
within like a year.
And I feel like there was
Google in there somewhere.
And it was almost like--
maybe as some metaphors, there
could be some oxygen. You know,
oxygen's always a good metaphor.
But, I mean, like--
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: You've got your
cigars, some breathing--
something in there.
Yeah.
Because I used to
like, if I would ever
get lucky, and be
like, oh, we're
going to fly you to
a TV show, so you
get to sit in the
front of the plane.
I was always asked to go
back to my seat in coach.
[LAUGHTER]
And then I would--
you pissed me off.
And I'm all, I've got
my ticket right here!
Why do you think I'm not here!
[LAUGHTER]
And then all of a sudden one
year, it's like, oh, Mr. Folds,
have a seat.
And that was like my
people had arrived.
[LAUGHTER]
And I feel like people
my age had ideas.
And the ideas took over.
And then that might
be something--
there would be something
like that in it,
and it would take me a while.
I would work off of
note cards for this one.
And I would probably
set myself up
with a little bottle of Scotch
for about four nights in a row,
lock myself in my room with note
cards, and a toy bass guitar.
AUDIENCE: What kind of
Scotch do you drink?
LAURA MURPHY: Oh,
that's a good question.
BEN FOLDS: Well, let's see.
You know, what when I'm on
tour, and not in a pinch.
I won't say that.
It doesn't sound nice.
But it's-- you can't always
get everything you want.
So Lagavulin is
always out there,
which is a real good bet.
Let's see.
I like Ardbeg, both the 12
and 16 ages are really nice.
There's some really kind of
rare whiskies that are basically
scotch that come from Tasmania,
Hobart, one called Lark,
and one called Nant.
Those are--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: --probably
the best I've had.
And they're kind
of like the Scotch
that you-- or the whiskeys
that you get in Japan,
the ones that won
all the awards.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LAURA MURPHY: I think you just
get an invite to the next Men
at Google Bourbon Night.
AUDIENCE: After the show.
AUDIENCE: Tonight
after the show!
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BEN FOLDS: Oh, awesome.
LAURA MURPHY: Tonight
after the show.
AUDIENCE: We have
the Lark [INAUDIBLE]..
BEN FOLDS: Really?
Lark's kind of hard to get
your hands on, that's really--
LAURA MURPHY: I
know where he lives,
so we can head back there.
Yeah.
BEN FOLDS: See, but
the thing is, is we're
heading right for that
fat cigar-smoking guy.
[LAUGHTER]
But really in about 20
years, we'll be that guy.
And these other people will
come along with these ideas,
and we'll be going, back when it
was Google, and it was proper.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: I don't
know about proper.
BEN FOLDS: Oh, you
know what I thought?
It just popped into my head.
When I was-- and I went
to an experimental school.
It called Moore
experimental school.
It was kind of a hippie,
completely public
it was like 50/50
racially integrated school
in the middle of the '70s.
So I was bused a long
way, went to this school,
and we sat on the floor.
We never used desks.
A lot of our class was
done in dry erase stuff.
And 90 people in a classroom,
sitting on the floor.
So it was a really
unusual school.
LAURA MURPHY: Was this
in North Carolina?
BEN FOLDS: North Carolina.
This was West [INAUDIBLE],,
North Carolina.
And we had a thing called
mini society, where we would
make a business for an hour.
You'd make a business,
and then that
would be that class
would the mini society.
And we all got to vote on what
we called the currency, when
I was in fourth grade.
So this is 1974, something like.
'75.
And I won with the name
of the currency that year.
And so that year, the currency
was called the Google.
That's true.
LAURA MURPHY: No.
BEN FOLDS: That's true.
LAURA MURPHY: Really?
BEN FOLDS: Yeah.
It was the Google.
That's what-- what I--
I'd made up the Google, so I--
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA MURPHY: Here you have it.
Best Google talk ever.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]